[Musique]
pour en débattre nous sommes avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
attiré amouroux porte-parole du syndicat
infirmier snpl syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france
alors évidemment cette question ce soir
est ce qu'il faut rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les personnels
soignants
vous êtes d'accord ou pas bertrand
legrand la rendre obligatoire
pourquoi pas enfin c'est en fait je
ferai des jeunes ou la permettre tout
simplement puisque aujourd'hui par
exemple moi qui souhaiteraient même
vacciné au plus vite
on ne me donne pas la possibilité de le
faire dans quelques mois la question que
j'ai envie de vous poser ces cas le
patient qui n'a pas envie de se faire
vacciner qui est prêt à me donner sa
dose c'est à dire quand vous dites que
pour l'instant ce n'est pas possible de
se faire vacciner
elle a pour l'instant on a décidé de
priorité et on ne doit pas décider qu'il
y avait du personnel qui méritait d'être
vaccinés prioritairement moi je suis
parfaitement scandalisé que les
personnels politiques
en partant du président mais aussi du
premier ministre ne sera pas vacciner
prioritairement c'est pas un passe-droit
c'est clairement les cécités si jamais
demain nos ingénieurs du nucléaire va
tomber tous malades et qu'on se
retrouver avec des centrales nucléaires
en perdition ce serait catastrophique et
donc il est hors de question de ne pas
prioriser la part est la vaccination en
fonction de ce que les personnels
apporte à la france et je pense que
c'est ainsi que comme ça les français
comprendront que oui il ya un vrai
intérêt stratégique à se vacciner avec
thierry amouroux vous êtes opposé cette
vaccination obligatoire pour les
personnels soignants qui n'est pour
l'instant pas envisagée par le
gouvernement
oui on pense que l'on doit rester dans
la même logique que la vaccination
contre la grippe
on pour la pour l'instant on manque de
de données scientifiques un retour sont
un peu bizarre je vais vous m'entendez
ouais on vous entend nous entend
poursuivre et d'accord donc au niveau
des données
il nous manque de deux choses
importantes
d'une part si on sait effectivement
qu'il ya la vaccination est très
efficace pour éviter les faits graves de
la maladie
à titre individuel par contre nous
n'avons pas de données sur la capacité
du vaccin à empêcher la transmission et
en particulier une fois que l'on est
vaccinée on peut être porteurs
asymptomatiques en ayant des virus dans
toute la sphère orl et donc rester
contaminants or l'intérêt de la
vaccination des professionnels de santé
n'est pas pour eux-mêmes parce qu'ils
sont le reflet de la population générale
mais avant tout une validation altruiste
pour empêcher leurs patients fragiles
d'être contaminés s'il n'y a pas des
faits avérés
ça va poser un souci le vaccin freezer
n'a pas de donné là dessus et au niveau
du moderna les données qui sont sortis
et c'est qu'on était contagieux entre
les deux injections
il n'y a pas eu d'autres d'autres
données ensuite
donc ça c'est un problème premier
problème le deuxième souci c'est que
nous sommes un certain nombre à avoir
déjà été le contaminer par le cos vie
lors de la première ou de la seconde
vague et donc nous avons des anticorps
est à ce stade le 18 décembre la has a
estimé que ne l'est pas lieu de signer
les personnes mais qui avait déjà eu
legault vide donc voilà on a ces deux
problèmes à résoudre alors on a une
chance vous parliez de la lenteur
française
ça va nous permettre de voir ce qui se
passe au niveau des états unis où il ya
deux millions de vaccinés les anglais il
ya eu 800 mille acide et on va avoir
plus de données et avoir les réponses à
nos questions
oui mais bertrand legrand sur cet
argument justement de la transmission du
virus pour lequel visiblement le le
vaccin ne ne ne peux rien faire
est ce que c'est un argument qui est qui
tient la route selon vous alors il ya
deux choses la première chose c'est que
une étude sur la contagiosité post
vaccinales ne peut avoir lieu qu'après
un certain délai et c'est ce qu'on a vu
par ailleurs dans d'autres vaccins
donc quand vous dites on n'a pas prouvé
bien sûr on n'a pas prouvé
et alors bien sûr qu'on a pas prouvé je
vois pas où est le problème
et je comprends pas où on veut faire
monter la sauce et la mayonnaise
évidemment qu'on n'a pas prouvé
puisqu'on n'a pas le temps nécessaire
pour permettre de prouver cela donc ça
c'est une chose qui était imparable pour
tout le monde donc tout les complotistes
on s'amusait à jouer sur cette année sur
cet argument
deuxième chose je voudrais vous rappelez
vous êtes infirmier
j'imagine que vous portez un masque
quand vous voyez vos patients - j'en
aime bien avant même qu'on me demande de
le mettre
donc la protection de mes patients elle
passe par la protection physique
le fait que je sois vacciner ne va pas
me faire libérer mais protection
physique
donc il n'y a aucun argument là dedans à
ne pas se vacciner la réalité c'est que
le vaccin oms et protège des formes
graves
les formes graves tous les gens qui
prennent une dose maximum et vos
infirmiers ne prenne une dose maximum
parce qu'ils sont au contact du patient
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai évité
à chaque fois pendant mais mon travail
d'envoyer des infirmiers dans le
domicile des patients qui est une bombe
virale j'ai pas envie qu'ils y aillent
sans protection donc moi personnellement
je suis désolé de vous le dire mais sur
la base des études scientifiques qui ont
été sortis du kaiser depuis maintenant
au moins deux semaines puisque j'avais
fait une interview avec vous il ya pas
longtemps et je n'ai pas les données
maintenant qu'on a
donner c'est quand même assez évident
que un lot dax 1 ne présente quasiment
aucun effet secondaire voire moins que
le placebo c'est quand même assez
impressionnant et qu'il est
particulièrement efficace pour éviter
les formes graves
bien sûr sur la contamination on va
devoir garder le masque au moins jusqu'à
ce qu'on ait soit au mois de juillet ou
au mois 2 août pour avoir le recul de
faire descendre à thierry amouroux
peut-être parce que je pense qu'il n'a
pas l'air d'apprécier qu'on parle de
complotisme oui bon je trouve ça assez
incroyable comme un aimant au moins en
tant que professionnels de santé on
applique que tous les vaccins
obligatoires
on se vaccine majoritairement contre la
grille pour protéger nos patients
fragiles mais entre les complotistes et
les j'accepte tous des injections des
injonctions gouvernementales
il ya une limite normal voilà nous on se
base sur des données scientifiques pour
l'instant on a constaté ces données
voilà c'est aux bovins le fait que ça
n'agissent pas sur la transmission n'est
pas de données sur l'action sur la
transmission c'est un fait objectif est
sûre le moderna on a vu que des gens qui
était séronégatif qui se sont fait
vacciner se sont retrouvés avec une pcr
positive voilà alors tiré à montrouge
juste et on voit que c'est quand même
étonnant de voir que les professionnels
de santé se montrent réticents à se
faire vacciner et dans le même temps ils
ont un peu aussi on peut l'imaginer
l'obligation d'encourager à l'étranger à
se vacciner moi personnellement si mon
médecin me dit je vais pas me faire
vacciner
je vais me poser des questions alors
qu'il me dit de le faire moi j'aime
poser des questions en sortant du
cabinet attention on parle de la
vaccination des professionnels de santé
qui sont le reflet bien lieu
excusez moi mais pour tous résidents en
ehpad
il est évident que il faut se faire
vacciner des possibles et la stratégie
grade b de la hs est très bien pour ça
parce que eux le risque de mourir d'une
forme grave du duc au vide est très
important par rapport aux effets
possibles l'éventuelle mandat vaccins
après et c'est comme pour tout la
vaccination comptes annuels contre la
grille ali ciblées sur les personnes les
plus fragiles les personnes âgées les
personnes atteintes de maladies
chroniques etc
voilà on est toujours dans du bénéfice
risque
et après s'il n'y a pas d'action sur la
transmission que les soignants vaccinés
seront toujours contaminants ben voilà
il ya ces les limites de la vaccination
a twist alors que lorsqu'on est vaccinée
contre la grippe
on n'est pas content amis n'ont alors
plus que vous parlez du bénéfice risque
il ya beaucoup de de personnel soignant
de médecins qui met en avant justement
son ratio bertrand legrand pour
convaincre justement les français à se
faire vacciner aussi ça c'est un
argument aussi qui est qui peut compter
je peux pas laisser dire que la
vaccination n'a qu'un rôle altruiste
c'est complètement faux la première
mesure que vous pouvez voir de tous les
tous les jours c'est la vaccination pour
le tétanos vous vacciner que pour vous
même le tétanos n'est pas transmissible
en interhumains donc la vaccination elle
a pour premier objectif le bénéfice
individuel
il est évident que tout professionnel de
santé a tout intérêt à se protéger
contre le coronavirus on a payé un lourd
tribut et j'ai pas envie de voir
d'autres personnes payées un des
attributs supplémentaires parce qu'on
tergiverse pendant 2 3 mois et la
deuxième chose c'est que lui le bénéfice
pour la population en général est
important et il ne se peut se mesurer
qu'à un an deux ans donc forcément on en
aura pas ces données là donc soit on
fait ce qu'on a fait l'esprit premier de
la classe et on va se planter parce que
sans vaccination
par jour franchement ça se mérite
vraiment de se poser la question de
savoir si on a les vaccins ou pas mais
on peut attendre on peut encore attendre
il y aura des morts et en plus fins et
complètement stupide donc les vraies
études ont été publiées
la pharmacocinétique a été publié on
sait comment agit de vaccins on sait
qu'elle a été la niveau de révolution
ces vaccins arn sont une véritable
révolution
les anglais ont pris la mesure des
choses avant nous alors même que l'on
n'avait pas des études je me demande
bien d'ailleurs comment ils ont fait
mais ils ont fait le bon pari et nous on
a fait le mauvais pari et on va
maintenant justifier cette pénurie en
faisant croire qu'il ya une raison pour
laquelle on vaccine trop lentement c'est
une grosse blague
enfin n'importe qui peut vacciner les
infirmiers comme les médecins
ça n'a absolument aucune difficulté
d'injecter c'est notre coeur de métier
et à nous mettre des barrières
administratives et à nous empêcher de
faire laver la vaccination
il n'y a qu'une seule raison c'est que
le vaccin n'est pas disponible ou n'est
pas livrables
justement est ce qu'il faut en arriver à
ce point là rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pour les personnels
soignants je reviens donc à cette
première question dans dans le même
temps c'est vrai que on se dit aussi que
vu la défiance des français vis à vis du
gouvernement et les français qui sont
très attachés à leur personnel soignant
on l'a vu durant toute cette crise
sanitaire finalement il ya aussi
peut-être un devoir d'exemplarité
nous rendrons la disponible et je pense
que le problème sera réglé ça sert à
rien de spéculer permettez moi de me
vacciner permettait à chaque infirmier à
chaque pharmacien à chaque enfin tout
personnel soignant de se vacciner vous
verrez qu'ils le feront personne n'a
envie de perdre le goût l'odorat ou se
retrouver en réanimation donc évidemment
que pour le bénéfice individuel nous
allons le faire c'est une évidence
non mais il ya quand même une réticence
un parmi les personnels soignants les
infirmiers un tir et amour ou encore une
fois il ya aussi le fait que nous sommes
nombreux à avoir été déjà contaminé et
donc nous avons les anticorps voilà est
par contre les études qui ont été faites
jusqu'à présent et
cuvée les gens qui étaient déjà porteur
du coc vide est exclu et les femmes
enceintes exclut les immunodéprimés
donc du coup il ya un certain nombre de
trous dans les faits et on ne sait pas
ce qu'il en est pour quelqu'un qui a des
anticorps du duc au vide de s'injecter
le vaccin juste un dernier mot pour
conclure parce que je le disais au début
de cette émission du révérend il s'est
exprimé chez nos confrères de france 2
il a parlé de cette campagne de
vaccination n'a dit que c'était normal
qu'on avance lentement peut-être plus
lentement que nos voisins et que ce
retard il sera à rattraper courant
janvier un canton c'est vous bah c'est
bien ça permet profiter justement du
rheu convainc à sur les américains et
les anglais il ya un certain nombre de
réticences parce que on sait que les
choses ont été fait rapidement
jova les vaccins de la population
générale les les quatre autres façons
prévu que à partir du printemps
donc là on aura suffisamment de recul
sur des millions de personnes et donc du
coup je pense qu'un certain nombre de
réticences vont vont tomber d'elle-même
la verna legrand rapidement merci
bernard legrand a rapidement bon c'est
tout simple chaque retard se paiera en
nombre de vies et en prix de confinement
je pensais que c'était vachement
important de ne pas se confiner et que
l'économie prime et surtout je comprends
pas de ne pas avoir aujourd'hui
d'entrepreneurs qui nous pousse à
vacciner la population pour éviter de
fermer leur entreprise
mais manifestement c'est plus le
problème du jour merci à vous deux merci
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
et thierry amouroux porte-parole du
syndicat infirmiers snpi syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
chiant